In quel periodo stavamo girando un
cortometraggio e la mia amica e collega
aveva il trucco scenico di un naso rotto il
problema è che quella sera aveva anche
il raffreddore quindi durante le pause si
infilava dei pezzi di carta nel naso per
evitare che tutto colasse solamente che le veniva da starnutire e niente io ho
beccato lo starnuto. Probabilmente se
inserirai questa cosa nel video
lei mi odierà a vita e l'amicizia sarà distrutta per sempre però dovevo farlo. Leti ti voglio
bene. Quindi quelli sono fazzoletti... Mamma che cosa, che cos'è secondo te? Pezzi
di carta... Ma che cosa poteva essere blocchi di marmo? Ma perché c'aveva un po'
di muco che le usciva dal naso no? Mamma mia...
Guarda... Leti comunque il tuo amico è una m***a. Ma non le dà fastidio? Eh sì la fa starnutire
come puoi ben vedere... Aaaaah ma lo starnuto viene
causato dal fazzoletto? Mamma non lo
so, stava male... Ma vogliamo chiamarlo a questo punto e chiedergli vita morte e
miracoli di Leti. Guardala... Questa qui è proprio, è l'emblema di questa puntata
questa foto.
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata. Il tema della
puntata di oggi è... FOTO VENUTE MALE
diciamo anche malissimo
quindi FOTO VENUTE MALISSIMO
Anzi FOTO MOSTRUOSE
Ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli Studios de Casa Mia
una persona che diciamo non è che ha
avuto a che fare con foto brutte
del sottoscritto cioè ce le ha proprio avute in 3d. Niente popò di meno che mia mamma. Ciaooo
Come va ma? Tutto a posto? Sei pronta?
Prontissima! Non ho preso
foto apposta anche perché ho delle foto
tue che sono abbastanza... Improponibili. Sì
ce ne ho una proprio improponibile tua secondo me. E qual è? La foto del tuo matrimonio... Vabbè ma la
ero carina... Mamma... Giovane e carina. Sì mamma ma avevi una faccia al patibolo, una donna
che veramente con 1 solo scatto ti fa
passare la voglia di sposarti per il
resto della tua intera esistenza. Sembra
sai quale la foto di Maria De Filippi
che si sposa con Costanzo... Oddio, io non c'ero. Al matrimonio?
No... Questa sei te... Mamma mia...
Eravamo a una festa di compleanno ci mettiamo tutti in posa, una mia amica
scatta la foto e il problema è che la
testa della ragazza al centro ha deciso
di non essere immortalata quindi adesso
ti allego il reperto di tutti i ragazzi
sorridenti meno una che non sapremo mai se stesse sorridendo o meno perché qualcuno si
è portato via la sua faccia. Ma questa è allucinante! Ma tu mi giuri che non è... Scusa dai
non ci posso credere, è assurdo. Non c'è una faccia ma soprattutto c'è quello che c'è dietro
la faccia, capito cosa intendo? Ci sta l'unione della spalla di lui con la spalla di...
Dell'altro ragazzo. Eh sì o ci prendono in giro loro o sennò c'è da preoccuparsi che questi
ragazzi... Ti prego, ti prego, ti prego, vai, vai. Si facciano
aiutare da un sacerdote esorcista... E poi che sono queste righe bia...
Ah questi sono i laccetti della felpa, di una
felpa col cappuccio... Già pensavi che cosa
che erano gli artigli di Satana che da dietro lo acchiappavano? Non è che mi ricordo granché di
questa foto come dan intuibile tuttavia
mi ricordo che per prendere quella
bottiglia d'acqua che nella foto tengo
stretta come se fosse la cosa più
importante del mondo
ho fatto praticamente una mezza capriola
in avanti però al rallentatore cioè non
sono morta ho ancora il collo funzionante
e  la mia migliore amica anziché
soccorrermi ha deciso di lasciarmi dieci
minuti così vedendo che emozione potessi provare e ha ripreso il tutto. Nooo vabbè...
Ecco cosa è successo alla ragazza della
foto prima eh capito? Lei ha fatto questo e poi è andata a
scattare la foto, insieme agli altri. Ecco qua, risolto l'arcano possiamo
dormire tranquilli? Dai, dai... Oh!
Ma che carinaaa, sembra Gianmarco... È verooo, Gianmarco da bambinooo
Gianmarco, quando era piccolo, era Eschimese cioè nel senso... Ma io non sto vedendo foto orribili...
Mamma ehm... Dove sono? Mo speriamo che arrivi qualche bel cofano così sei contenta.
Allora, qui abbiamo delle foto interessanti, vediamo un pochino
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite. Lo scenario è questo, Gardaland come puoi vedere siamo io e
mia cugina e abbiamo avuto la brillante idea di
stampare queste due foto e insomma spero che possano migliorarvi la
giornata ciaooo.
Non so se te o la cugina sembrate Bono
degli U2... No anche John Lennon... Cioè qui lei stava pensando
ho lasciato tipo il gatto sul fuoco capito? Come se non fosse partecipe di quello che sta
facendo... Ma non lo vedi? Si sta proprio divertendo come... Come una pazza
Fammi vedere l'altra?
Questa era quella che stava dietro...
E qua... Sta morendo... Da quando è scesa da quella lì, a quando è salita su quest'altra giostra, sono passati
40 anni. Cioè qui è distrutta dalla vita...
È stravolta... È stravolta, è dis... È devastata. Guarda lei... Ha le occhiaie poverina! Lei, lei ha pers... Lei è la
figlia del peccato in questo momento. Ma
come fatto? Che non assomiglia per niente
a questa ragazza qui! No, questa è carina. Sì! Piccola precisazione io sono quella coi
capelli rossi, mia cugina è quella con la magliettina a righe. Lei sembra passare a miglior vita. Sì!
Ciao, ciao. Secondo me l'hanno accolta a fine corsa con un sacco nero. Sei soddisfatta già?
Incominciano a essere... Io c'ho una foto per esempio bruttissima ero un po' una balena
spiaggiata quindi c'era sta fotografia
di me sulla spiaggia che avevo Gianluigi
di pochi mesi, orribile... Ecco io quella non la faccio vedere, non
la farei vedere... Io pure ho una foto che
non farei vedere mai ma a te la farò vedere di
nascosto. Me l'ero scattata io per vedere... C'erano i selfie all'ora? All'ora piano con... Eh ma anche tu cominci ad avere
cioè mica sei tanto piccolo...
Se volevi ferirmi ci sei riuscita. Mamma sembro Fiona di Shrek
Questo è il periodo dello sviluppo perché si alterano i lineamenti in quella, in quella
fase di crescita... Sembro Fiona di Shrek... Eh sì è vero. La mandai a Vega per dirle "Ti prego!
guarda che cosa è successo ti prego!" In
realtà lei mi ha detto "Perfetto, ho qualcosa
per ricattarti per la pensione" E quindi
lei tiene ancora questa foto... Che non si sa mai.
Per ricattarmi in modo che magari ha una
pensione assicurata in futuro sperando
capito di potermi rovinare. Maledetta... Vedi a fidarsi degli amici? Andiamo avanti
Di ottimo umore questa bambina... Sì, era felice quel giorno
Sulla sinistra puoi vedere me vestita da lavatrice con un costume home made e invece sulla
destra mia sorella travestita da dalmata
assassino probabilmente non aveva ancora
capito la differenza tra carnevale e
halloween
dimmi che non ti spaventeresti se te la
vedesse spuntare da dietro un angolo
Oddio però non è fatta benissimo... Mamma e che dovevano fare? La lavatrice dico... E che dovevano murarla dentro
una lavatrice vera sta ragazzina? No ma
perché dorata? Ma così è carnevale! No si
vede che lo è
Mia madre è una rompipalle per quanto
riguarda i costumi perché veramente lei
quando era piccola non distingueva
halloween dal carnevale. Tu, a carnevale, ti vestivi da boia con una testa in mano
no? Però quando mi sono vestita da boia
ero già una ragazza eh. Beh sì ci sta
comunque è il tipico vestito per il ballo dei 18 anni... Il boia. No non può essere la stessa
"La foto con mostrato al parrucchiere e
il risultato. Ho pagato in lacrime, ho
cambiato parrucchiera tre anni e ancora
ridiamo di questa foto" No, scusa non è la stessa persona dai... No, è lei che ha
detto voglio questi capelli e questi
sono quelli che le hanno fatto
No, non l'ho capito. Mamma, che vuol dire che non l'hai capito? Allora... Queste
sono due persone diverse giusto? Mi
sembra evidente. Benissimo. Ok. Dopodiché. Lei ha mandato un
messaggio... Si... Dov'eri quando io leggevo quel messaggio? Allora...
Scusa un po'... Ogni tanto... Ogni tanto ma? È da quando sei arrivata, da quant'è?
Basta, non parlo più. Io non capisco perché ti ostini a invitarmi. No mamma, non lo so, è perché in realtà
doveva venire un'altra persona che ha
dato buca all'ultimo... Ah! Allora io sono un ripiego?
Mamma ma ovvio, Io se fosse per me non
ti chiamerei mai. Ah ma tu non mi avevi detto
che... Ti hanno dato buca! No, scherzo, in
realtà volevo te... Ah va bene... Vega... Aaaaah e certo perché lei ti
avrebbe sporcificato ben bene. "Non so come né perché so solo che stavo uscendo da una
discoteca e mi hanno chiesto se volevo una foto" Più che altro poverina sembra che le
abbiano spezzato il collo
sembra che abbia i capelli così lunghi che
le si sono tipo bloccati nel tacco eh. Ed è tutto all'insegna del torcicollo. Anche la mano ha
piuttosto grande. Mamma, è di questa ragazza qui in primo piano la mano... È sempre una mano...
No, non voglio che la gente pensa che uno prenda in giro. E allora stai
attenta in maniera deliziosa e discreta
a prendere in giro in maniera simpatica. Va bene...
E non da bulla quale tu sei. Allora lui non
apprezza le foto con il flash... Lui ha una
manona... Questa è vera? Ci stiamo soffermando sulle letture delle mani della gente
Oddio, Oh Dio santo... Ciao Gu, quella che ti mando è una delle mie foto preferite che come puoi vedere rappresenta
un santino di Gesù che mi tiene neonata
e decapitata tra le mani. È stata
realizzata completamente da mia nonna che lei la tiene nel portafoglio e la mostra
con estremo orgoglio a amici, conoscenti,
parenti chiunque. Niente quindi eccomi
decapitata tra le mani le signore. Fammi prendere la testa di mio nipote, gliela
mettiamo in mano a Gesù... L'idea no se
quella era l'idea ha fatto agah...
Madooo... Mamma mia... "La Pera, olio su tela. Analisi dell'opera: Ciao Gu, un normale pomeriggio trascorso in piscina ritrae
la mia migliore amica che in preda a un'apparentemente e ingiustificato atto di
follia, mi strappa la GoPro dalle mani e
immortala questo scatto che è stato
nominato da noi La Pera, a causa della
deformazione più che evidente che ha assunto
il suo volto" Ma cioè è terribile, come quan... Sì, terribile! Ma che ha in faccia? Ah è sott'acqua
Ragazzi... Perché mi guardi a me? Se parli ti guardo... Comunque siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video, mamma io ti
ringrazio perché ogni volta... Grazie a te. Ogni volta che tu finisci sul mio canale sai comunque di... Anche
se sono un ripiego. No mamma, grazie
davvero di cuore in realtà volevo te sin dall'inizio
No vabbè scherzi a parte. Ti ringrazio la prossima volta sarai la prima
scelta, te lo posso garantire. E non più un ripiego. Che dire io ringrazio voi per aver seguito questo
video fino ad adesso come sempre vi chiedo di farmi sapere quali sono state le vostre
esperienze con il tema della puntata e
anche di farmi sapere magari secondo voi
quali potrebbero essere delle puntate che
vi piacerebbe vedere in futuro
fatemele sapere qua sotto... Carnevale. Mamma allora vatti, fatti... Commentalo!
Carnevale, commentiamo tutti quanti
questo video con carnevale, carnevale per
rendere felice mia madre perché questa
puntata esilarante di carnevale la
stiamo aspettando tutti quanti. Se volete
essere aggiornati su tutto quello che
postiamo iscrivetevi, attivate la
notifica e che dire...
Cioè anche basta ecco cioè. Poi se volete lasciarmi pure, non lo so, il vostro DNA
Enrico... Pronto Enrico, dimmi. Aspetta Erri, Erri, un secondo solo. Puoi chiudere il video
per me? Ok, ehm... Chiudo il video di Vita Buttata
Che professionista! Pippo Baudo, sei veramente il Pippo Baudo del web
grazie mille! Madre santa. Vabbè l'ha fatto
no? Sì... Andata! Ok, grazie Gu, ciao a tutti... Ah è vero
scusa. Hai salutato, contenta? Eh certo, mica sono un'ineducata